today on our show more [__] trailers
than a Kentucky trailer park or or two
that's right two trailers two trilers
we're look at two trailers today right
here on Batman on
Batman 10 11
12 educated on Sesame Street right yes
products of Sesame Street children's
television Workshop mother yes TV is
your teacher uh welcome to Fat Man on
Batman as I brush you away I'm Kevin
Smith Mark Bernard [__] off from our
show that's how we welcome people
chasing them away uh we send you mixed
messages all the time just like a boy in
school that pulls a girl's pigtail we
like you but we're mean I beckon you
hither and push you away till we figure
out how to come once we figure out
orgasm then forget it then it's all
beckon beckon please becking and then
becking that [__] up pushing it into
your hand but with your you're on board
not your I don't want creepy no it's
like what what wakanda sex you like we
just wakanda sex did you just make a
reference to Black Panther I totally did
I seize that opportunity get out of that
dark hole wakanda sex I wonder what kind
of sex they have in wakanda that's Jerry
Seinfeld very nice if Jerry Jerry
Seinfeld met a black
guy make that
joke um this we to wakanda on the
[__] show yes uh or today on the show
we're going to look at trailers that
came out last week now one of them came
out the other day yes this week M um
well the first one we're looking at of
course is the Batman ver v Superman
trailer the final trailer which they D
this is the final and nobody warned us
this was coming it just dropped last
week one day I guess was it attached to
Daredevil or something yes was itach
Daredevil uh not Daredevil Deadpool
Deadpool no it just dropped in the
middle of the week like post Super Bowl
but pre Deadpool and not only did it
drop but it seems to have effectively
flipped the audience yet again for it
seems like everyone that was like Boo
about that second trailer are now like
Yay with little Flags I'm like huh
Turkish Airlines yeah that we talked
about that that was puzzling but still
interesting approach people who were
like huh about Turkish Airlines [__]
the next day that trailer came out and
everyone's like oh he can be on any
number of obscure expensive oversees
Airlines as long as he punches people
like that they showed them a Batman that
they've never seen in the movies before
they've shown him an Arkham Knight
Batman oh my God and everyone went
batshit like [__] nuts dude I mean
this was a scene I was told about or a
moment I was told about early on in
production there was somebody who was
just like dude I'm telling you there's a
moment in this movie where he comes up
through a floor and proceeds to kick 12
people's asses but it's like it's Batman
from Dark Knight returned he's grabbing
a [__] slamming his head in the
floor while throwing a batarang while
[__] doing this bunch of things at
once we get to see his camaraderie with
Alfred in the trailer where Alfred's
piloting the Batwing and they've got
little conversation stuff going back and
forth Jeremy Irons making a wonderful uh
Alfred Moder day Alfred Jeff John's
Alfred so he's got some War training and
[__] like that or military training M
six perhaps m i a little bit m i six
action bringing some of that Bond
action he's a double O he's a Batman's
Batman um Batman's Batman oh that was
awesome um but the first minut of this
tra seems like a response to the second
to the reaction a response to the
response of the second trailer yes which
you totally which and we all remember
that second trailer right where kind of
nothing happens but everything's on fire
yeah and everybody was like what the
[__] going on like every doday really
I didn't eat to see doomsday what they
had everyone with that first trailer and
then the second trailer felt like they
lost not everybody but they lost a bunch
of people like this what the [__] this
look like a video game or the boy what's
his name ball boy Lex Luther in the
movie irritated people in the trailer
and stuff so less of him in this third
trailer this third trailer is more about
like look here's [__] Batman doing
what you like to see Batman doing a
movie but you've never seen him doing a
movie before yeah it reminds me a lot of
the way I sort of felt when I saw I mean
granted as shitty as episode one was you
for the first time got to see Jedi who
were not old men and not like asmatics
and had all of their limbs and you got
to see people react to him too like Jedi
are here holy Dum [__] like oh we're
fighting for real like we're moving
these lightsabers for real like this is
the Batman always wanted on screen but
never got and even Christian Bale as
good as he was the action wasn't like
this what's in his hand is that a batang
looks like a bang he's about to stab a
fool with a batang God damn it like you
know I'm happy for that dude man I'm
proud of him and [__] like proud I had
nothing to do with it but I'm like of
all the [__] Batman's that look like
right now is the you know from now until
the end of time Batman will move this
cinematically [__] yes beautiful if
not better as the future moves on but
right now his is the Difference Maker M
this is the Batman that suddenly you're
like oh my God like that's it looks like
the video games isn't that weird that's
the standard now like that used to be a
dirty word man a few years ago people
like it looks like a video game and now
people like it looks like a video game
yeah how weird man but like they're
right it [__] looks like those
interstitials or it looks like the
fighting action in the [__] gamees
yeah like and I want to know that my
Batman [__] what is it called like
throw punch [__] you grabb me
you're like ah boom slam him on the
floor jumping over [__] Cape flying I
don't even know who those fools were but
I'm kill them all B doesn't matter oh
it's [__] phenomenal it religious man
they're just inside traitor just [__]
kill
them turn your radio down
bam oh it was [__] religious um they
didn't give us much more of the plot in
this trailer look at them dude look at
him what a specimen [__] man I mean
that's all Affleck body maybe he's got
some CG help whatever that does a CG
with the cape and [__] the movement
and [__] but like Zack Snider dude God
damn I want if if I ever get in a fight
in life I want Zack Snyder behind me
going like do this this is your
combination I want him playing me like
xxyx y up Kevin there are 12 working
defenses from this position we all love
that Batman L we all love that Batman L
this dos this this is this one of them
kills one of them hurts hurts um it was
uh I think it was smart way smart for
them to [__] put this trailer out yes
um anybody online it seemed like who was
like [__] this after the second one
immediately [__] 180 again they were
like Yay this did you see that part when
when Superman goes to punch Batman and
Batman blocks the punch and that [__]
look on his face that was weird that was
the thing that a lot of people reacted
to in a Big B way the trailer button
which I you know is very effective but
for me I'm like [__] opening that
trailer is what sells me this moment
here I was like oh that's yeah I guess
that would happen right but everyone
else in the world who maybe don't like
see that on a regular basis in books or
you know dream about that when they go
to sleep at night like I I dream of
Batman block and Superman sponge that
captured their [__] look at is that
his [__] boot going in his face that
is his boot going in face that captured
their imagination dude where they're
like holy [__] Batman blocked the punch
and Superman was [__] shocked yeah
because the entire like everybody's
conception of Superman V Batman is it's
[__] Superman and they've said it in
the last couple of trailers before this
one like I could kill you if I wanted to
and just that shot where it's like no I
don't think you could kill me if you
wanted to like we got to fight guys
there's a nice moment too where just
like if there's even a 1% chance like
he's could kill us and could kill us off
there's even one but we have to that
sounds like Batman it totally does you
know what I'm saying that's cool like
harsh overreaction
yes if there's even a 1% chance we have
to burn him to the ground I who never
kill anybody will kill this alien this
dude drawing a line and that dude's on
the other side of that line I will
totally [__] kill that guy somebody
give me bullets for the first time in my
life I'm going to shoot [__] yeah I
Alfred switch out the rubber bullets put
in the real metal bullets and you know
what that means to me cuz my parents and
bullets and blah blah blah the whole
thing but [__] do it [__] look at
me I'm already this [__] look how
jacked he is dude in the metal armor and
[__] oh [__] love it he's got the bat
lips and then everyone forgot because
Deadpool happened and people were like
[__] this holy [__] oh man we man I feel
a little bad for Warner Brothers cuz
every time they do a thing that feels
like it's awesome you guys we won
Deadpool awesome you guys did oh [__]
Daredevil trailer oh you [__] guys
they did they right [__] as if you
know they had a moment they had a moment
like right before the [__] weekend
then Deadpool happened and that's all
anyone wanted to think about and then on
Monday morning you know it's like all
right let's get back to the business of
Batman v Superman come on you guys but
Marvel was just like oh you want to see
superheroes fight we have a trailer for
that as well by the bye oh do you want
it to be dark also and kind of Broody
and kind of underly is it a street level
hero fighting somebody with a different
ethos than him but they're both on on
the side of right well here's [__]
Daredevil season 2 they dropped the
Daredevil season 2 [__] Batman v
Superman
trailer on Monday and they're doing like
similar story it kind of totally is and
but I don't care I'm I'm not like oh
[__] man I'm going to see this twice
dude I want to see this every [__]
every weekend this summer I want see
superheroes misunderstanding French
bedroom farce fights where they're like
we're enemies and then they fight until
like no we're buddies like oh yeah know
this Super Friends I'm all for it
exactly how you get to Super Friends is
super punching and [__] yes this trailer
was wonderful John Baron thought you
can't protect the
Rick that's that guy [__] you can't
protect him Rick now he's playing The
Punisher and he's [__] genius dude
you're not saving this city you can't
protect a man
Murdoch look at him dude he's [__] he
looks like Robert dairo in [__] taxi
driver very much so um and if that's the
vibe they're going for [__] a it
seems to be [__] you and take all my
money Netflix and got my money anyway
but I would pay twice in a month for
that [__] oh two times quick for that
Daredevil the footage I saw and then
also they end their trailer going like
end of part one of
trailer which that's the world we're in
we're in the world of teaser trailers
for trailers trailers part one and two
there it is Trailer part two drops in a
week I'm sure the trailer part two is
going to be all about Electra well she
finishes off this trailer and that was
nice cuz just when you're sitting there
going Jesus Christ they [__] nailed
Frank Castle and anybody that's like
where's his skull hey man Daredevil
didn't get
dressed until like the last two episodes
of season one so don't go looking for
the [__] skull in his chest but that
dude in the trailer and that dude in the
picture sitting in the [__] chair
that is Dar that is Punisher he don't
need a [__] skull on his chest yes
he's [__] there dude that is so
[__] Frank Castle when he's like at
the end of the trailer he's just like
you're just one bad day away from being
me so good and this seems like a moment
where Karen's looking at his x-ray maybe
she going start figuring out that Matt
pie yeah she putting it together there
he is dude he's haunted he's haunted by
the death of his half measure [__]
yes call him a half measur you're weak
you're a coward you can't protect him
R do it once in the show I'll be um man
this is like a dream come true dude I
mean my one fear though is that it looks
like it's the Punisher show starring
Daredevil I'm okay with that you know a
whole season of Daredevil the Kingpin
show well actually no we had a whole
season of the Daredevil show Matt
Murdoch show become a daredevil he's
there you got to introduce like the new
element his his you know he's always
going to be fighting crime MH but his
big bad this year seems to be the
Punisher who is also fighting crime just
in a different way I mean it is Batman v
Superman Marvel's so smart to [__] I
don't know if that was planned or if
they were like [__] him like it just
seems like a real like what are they
doing across the
street
[Music]
[__] it we're doing it too sorry about
that whoops we made a thing kind of like
your thing you can do we can do equally
as good there he is man holy [__]
[__] love it at one point he had like
a black uh front of the helmet on like
in few of the shots you think that's an
addendum or is it a battle damage I
think it's battle damage I think the
some of the leather guy I think you can
see there's like a seam where he welds
it a little bit yeah oh that's [__] up
dude so he'll have this like [__]
broken mask and [__] oh Charlie lips
that's cool right he's good man that
dude's so good I saw him I finally that
boy's good I CAU up his
name Amica that Bo I caught up with
Theory of Everything finally a year
after it came out with with the actor
boy who won an Oscar yes uh Eddie redm
yes the the Stephen J Hawking thing and
Charlie Cox is in that movie really the
British Charlie c not the American
Charlie C no he's very British but uh
he's the dude who helps out the Hawking
family when Stephen Hawking gets like
super invalid does he help him out by
putting on a red suit and [__] alas no
he helps him out by [__] his wife
[__] oh really he [__] his wife behind
his back didn't is that what he did on
[__] uh on on Broad what was it a
Boardwalk Empire as well yeah I think
he's got killed spoilers [__] by the way
um but yes he there's a whole romance
between Jane Hawking and this guy he's
he's fantastic he's really good in that
yeah good for him he got classy movies
to do but also he got this and this is a
classy showy British movies plus this
and very comic Booky indeed very Punchy
TV action very Punchy they show another
all WiFi I was like what did people like
the first time they love the good H all
right like let's leave that up and look
at that outfit real quick like it's
[__] cool though like he's adding
pieces it looks like like he's having to
augment and [__] any place it definitely
looks better than the tail end of the
first season costume where I was like
you looked like an action figure but now
he looks like a dude who's been through
some [__] it's like I needed to work
better than that but still no uh DD yet
everyone's waiting for the [__]
emblem on his chest not everybody and
you know what if you're waiting for that
get a [__] life are you kidding me
how awesome would it be if in like the
ninth episode of 10 Frank Castle has him
down takes out a knife and just scrawls
the DD on his chest d d hire
this I want to see his Daredevil now
that'd be good dude would it be awesome
I like that um holy [__] [__] this I
I honestly between bvs and DD
BP sounded filthier than a
minute like this could be the this could
be the end of my life dude seriously
I've seen a Star Wars movie I'm seeing
Batman fight Superman and Batman wear
the armor I've now seen Deadpool and I
didn't even know how badly I wanted to
see it and [__] we're going to see
[__] more dared fight in the Punisher
with Electra as we see at the tail end
of it like bvs suicide squad there's a
new Ghostbusters coming great [__]
time to be alive anybody out there who's
just like life sucks this world's bad
you pull him aside you show them any one
of these [__] trailers man he'll turn
that frown upside down it's good time to
be alive what don't You' like about
things because these are all good
things stop being such a [__] like Game
of Thrones what did you all to like
about things cuz these are good things
speaking of Game of Thrones there is a
teaser little baby teaser did you see it
I did see it yes you think uh it's it
seems as if HBO is just trying to make
fans
upset oh because they put faces in the
because it takes place in House of the
undying I'm going to
say where Ario was hanging out with the
guy who was like a girl wants to clean
the floor pretty much and she's like a
girl does not [__] a Girl Wants Revenge
I'm want to kill some [__]
jacking Hagar [__] you he made her give
her [__] away and like threw her [__]
into the ocean and [__] yeah so she went
BL spoilers at the last episode she was
like I can't say I can't [__] say
maybe that wasn't the exact performance
but you all know so she lost her sight
she lost her sight but so that is where
they train these you know faceless
people to be the master assassins take a
face from the wall and go out and be
just be that person but all the people
who have faces on the wall are dead and
so this teaser is just scrolling through
and getting little audio clips from
people that we've known and loved in
Game of Thrones who we're now dead right
and then so you get like Ned Stark and
you get Caitlyn Stark you get Rob Stark
you get you know the people you love but
then like right [__] there they put
Tyrion in there who's not dead who's
that that's John Snow they're putting a
lot of people that better not be dead
because if all these [__] are dead we
got no show right so there's Sansa
there's there's Tyrion there's Daenerys
it's like you [__] ain't dead
if it's all if all these people are dead
then the show is going to be about the
dickas
dude yes it will be I'm all for man The
Adventures of Lord varis Joy no man
Theon gjy the other dickas dude the the
uh the unic who's on the small Council
that's right those two could team up and
[__] they could be like Deadpool and
Colossus teaming up like they can have
an offshoot [__] Game of Thrones show
where it's like you don't have a dick
neither do I yay and they get into jams
and help people out I know you guys
figure it out awesome theme song yeah
[__] we're going on a trip without
dicks and just a couple of dudes looking
for their dicks getting up to all kinds
of Tricks da da when you think that
life's got odd just remember you can
make it without a rod it's [__] Duo
Duo time Rosen cron Gilda Stern have no
dicks George RR
Martin we got this
yo um let's look at other news uh in
trailer news there is a teaser for the
trailer of Ghostbusters coming which is
[__] dude [__] no like listen I'm
off what they do what was it just that
simple pretty much is that and I think
it's like who you going to call and and
do they say like a date or something
what the [__] is that is that a piece of
footage I think it's a piece of yeah was
that in the teaser yeah they showed this
yeah clearly we haven't seen this teaser
yeah we haven't they showed cops then
they showed the military and then they
said who you g to call that's the [__] I
say in the teaser Matt was good enough
to watch it cuz we couldn't be bothered
apparently yes I was told it was just
like the symbol so I'm like I a watching
that but they showed actual footage so
they showed the cops they show the
military like cops racing out and
between all those they said who you
going to call wow they end with this the
symbol wow I sat I went to SNL this
weekend and I saw the director there
Paul Paul F Paul F he was sitting there
watching the show it was really weird
watching him rock out to
Kanye Kanye was performing and they were
performing like ultral light beam which
is not really a [__] not too much
dance song but he was just just grooving
on it oh my God I was I was I couldn't
help sco
smiling that like a 50
guys well he had three of his four
Ghostbusters in that show night that's
what I'm saying man he had Kate McKinnon
was there Melissa mcarthy and uh Leslie
Jones Leslie Jones all they were missing
was uh Christen wigs Kristen wigs I
thought maybe she was going to show up
but but Melissa McCarthy was there for
the other movie The Boss the boss but um
you know that there will be come like
May or June well when is Ghostbusters
coming I I want to say yeah I want to
say it's either late June or early July
but she was phenomenal on SNL that and
the trailer for the boss I think looks
good like I watch Melissa all four those
women are funny I'll watch him do
anything and that guy he made like
[__] dance like an old white man at
Kanye he has no [__] he can't help it
but that dude made some funny [__]
movies man like the heat is a very funny
movie Bridesmaids bridesmaids is an
hysterical [__] movie Spy is a really
[__] funny movie as well the guy's I
think he's gifted Storyteller and stuff
um but uh but yeah that movie looks
[__] I'm ready dude I know you know I
think everyone's over the whole girl
Ghostbusters thing and now we're just
ready to get down to a Ghostbusters
movie they are except that they aren't
Because the Internet are [__] [__]
people still talking about that [__]
they're still talking about that [__]
they're like you know for the same
people who want to boycott the NFL for
having Beyonce do a halftime show that
they might not have liked right they're
also like you mark let's be honest it
was a little too
musical way too musical too many notes
is that simple take out a few notes
which ones would you like me to take out
did you see the performance I did see
the did you see the SNL Trail the day
turn black I don't Beyonce really this
not our Beyonce it's normally for
us what um yeah man I'm ready for
Ghostbusters I don't give a [__] if it's
women or [__] like Chipmunks I'll
even watch a chipmunk Ghostbusters me a
good [__] movie that's all I want and
this dude directing Paul F is a good
track record to make a good [__]
funny movies with a lot of these same
[__] players so it's like he's worked
with Kristen wig he's worked with
Melissa McCarthy the only one he hasn't
worked with is Kate M Ken and Leslie
Jones yeah and you know [__] dude I'm
telling you I saw in that in that movie
The Heat the guy who plays um their boss
who was you know [__]
uh in uh Back to the Future where he's
like they're beating down B Melissa
McCarthy's beating down boss and like he
he's like um do you know how old I am
and she's like I don't know like 55 he's
like I'm 36 or something like that he
looks so [__] like old and beaten
weather beaten and [__] and he goes like
he goes my 12-year-old son calls me
Grandpa like oh that made me laugh so
[__] hard if you could get gold out
of that like just the the [__] boss
character for like three minutes oh
forget it yeah you're going to be good
with ghost yeah I just think that there
is there is a segment of the audience
who has never ever had their toys taken
away from them and are now like but my
toys were dude toys and now you're
giving me lady toys and I don't like it
so much oh my God I'll take lady toys
lady toys make you come too lady toys
are the best toys my
friend it works just as well on dudes
man lady toys work for men as well made
for a lady but strong enough for a man
looks like a pump feels like a
sneaker I want this movie dude I'm ready
to see Ghostbusters give it to me give
it to what else they giv to us man let's
look uh let's see jumping around the
news as always we our new from the
internet some people bitched online like
oh you guys read [__] stories don't
watch it's all good there is your
[__] your your hardest first world
problem has just been solved by me and
Mark don't [__] watch turn off we're
going to read the news like they do in
Russia say listen we're doing your
service we're saving you from having to
learn to read or read the
internet which is fr with Peril because
you could be going to read about
Ghostbusters wind up with a dick in your
face you know happens to the best of us
yeah usually by choice Star Wars episode
8 just when we were like right on we got
used to Star Wars episode seven nope
life keeps moving it keeps on moving
there it is eight never have three Roman
numerals meant so much to so many people
eight is happening they've announced
some new cast which includes Benicio del
Toro um laa always amazing Laura D from
[__] Jurassic Park amongst the many
things but you most a wild heart we'll
give it a Wilder heart welome good Paul
dude have you noticed the buildup and
traffic lately how your mind works is
God's Own mystery
peanut um what a great film uh wonder
what she's playing anybody know have
they said they haven't said uh sweet
[__] all about so they're just like
they're in it happening don't you worry
and it's still Ryan Johnson yeah they
they they announced it by a little video
shoot of him on the set really just
saying and cut everybody that's our
first day on Star Wars episode 8 oh so
they [__] they they're already
shooting yeah look at him he's so happy
he was a nice boy he was on uh
that nicey what the [__] is that what
that's haml is that from the new yep
really the Jedi abides my friend the
Jedi abides are they literally starting
where they ended yeah pretty sure it's
like oh hey remember last time that's
crazy so JJ's like I got to work with
Mark Hill for two minutes [__] Ryan
John's like I got him the whole time
from the opening day one I just love the
idea of Mark Hamel sitting there for the
script reading of episode 7 just like I
came all this way I actually have no
[__]
lines oh here I at the end and yeah Luke
is on a Mountaintop looks over at Ray
with purpose the end can I just like add
Li a May the force something nothing
just like how's your mom I can't wait
till the Looper boy shows up I get some
dialogue in these movies um wow man
they're already starting starting you
know hats off to Hollywood man I know
everyone's always like [__] in their
mouth and being like I [__] suck dude
they're just lining up the happy like
[__] Jets like in a snowstorm just
stacking and [__] racking them man
and it's like every few months now
something wonderful is happening yeah
it's ni like we're getting spoiled it's
very American to have this much joy all
the time and it's not good because when
the when it all goes away somehow or
when we hit the doldrums or whatever the
[__] it's going to be hard this is like
the 80s of n Nerd movie it's like we're
all just high on coke and driving in
Ferraris and strippers and everywhere
and they're making movies that are like
80 satisfying you know what I'm saying
like with with like 90 sensibility and
20 20th century storytelling techniques
and [__] like that but they're as wholly
satisfying as like oh my God he beat the
Predator like [__] like that like BOS
cop you give me another one of these
thank you I I submit to you that
Deadpool is Beverly Hills Cop with a
costume oh I I just made that up in the
spot but I mean it's that [__] good
and that funny and [__] like that um all
right man so Star Wars amen is happening
who is Kelly Marie TR she's been added
as well uh I don't know her she's also
in that would be her she's mostly like
col humor like online web stuff o they
got a YouTube Star relative newcomer
right on all right good for her she's in
the Star Wars Universe too we got an
actual Asian person in Star Wars Co
[__] figure they had one in the last
one though remember the dude um listen
to me they got one
Mark another guy remember in like when
they're talking about the battle on Star
Killer base there was a guy who supposed
I also think being Rogue one is right
think so he's a friend of JJs he's been
a lot of stuff there's one dude I
remember like you're getting there man
next one Hollywood [__] Hollywood
normally like people crap on them but
I'm telling you dude there is a lot of
Joy like they're giving us some good
[__] my friend smart things I'm I'm just
happy with Hollywood for Deadpool you're
so good Hollywood this week you are good
speaking of everything that started
production yes Guardians of the Galaxy
volume two excellent segue and excellent
[__] film and probably excellent sequ
oh look at that they got chairs they got
chairs [__] a it must be happening
because when a studio spends money on a
chair back that's the green light right
there listen you can't just have
11-year-old kid sewing that stuff
willy-nilly you have a reason they
pulled a big trigger on that one wow man
wow I can't believe they're making a
sequel to that movie seems risky Mark
I'm not entirely sure you're thinking of
the same movie I'm thinking of I can't
wait to see that movie oh my God another
fun movie to look forward to and [__]
but yeah there apparently will be a real
title announced at some point cuz I
don't think they're just call Vol yeah
because you know awesome makes volume
two but I think that they are going to
in the
next so yesy much and who are the rumors
Matt who his dad um there have been a
lot of rumors none of them confirmed
anybody you got an idea Kurt Russell was
the last rumor but who in the Marvel
Universe you think they're going to make
him somebody I heard Nova or no or
Marvel that's what I heard
Marvel that was like shot down by James
gun I think James gun says not Marvel
marille the dad my guess is one of the
eternals you think his dad's one of the
eternals Matt [__] that's good gas
from produc that is he blackbolt will he
just not say
anything and then he [__] gets him to
Dad just say one thing he's
like planets are cutting in half and
[__] might be a mentor who stand as a d
also really o I love this [__] I love
this [__] as much as I love real human
beings that I care for and that came out
of my wife's body it's right up there
with my kid they had I I only had one
kid cuz I had more time to love this
[__] if I had more than one kid who'd
have time for this once upon a time MC
was in talks to be in this thing as the
dad but now it seems that he's going to
be in a little Stephen King joint called
The Dark Tower he's going to be the
Gunslinger he's going to be the man in
Black really Idris Elba is going to be
the gunser really when did this happen
they're in talks and Stephen King
confirmed that it's like listen there's
still negotiations but I'm prettyy sure
it's going to happen idra Al is the
Gunslinger yep and MCC is the man in
Black and it's a feature it's a feature
I don't I think they might have
abandoned it's a universe right it's a
universe they're doing a whole gun Dark
Tower Universe they're doing television
and movies starting in TV and going to
movies starting in movies the the
original plan when when Ron Howard was
directing this for Universal back in the
day was going to be movie 10 episode TV
series movie 10 episode TV series movie
that's that's what they talked about
doing with the xiles back in the day and
got a little bit like it was a few
seasons in movie right but like the
story would like you would have to go
they would they would play it Marvel
style like it's all connected it's all
[__] smart man back when Javier
Bardem was supposed to be the Gunslinger
and that fell apart When Things Fall
Apart you already played a gunslinger
for the colen brothers pretty much um
but so yes that is the last that is the
latest in the Dark Tower news which
[__] injes ala dude I don't even give
a [__] about Dark Tower be honest with
you I'm not even a dark tower fan I'm
glad it's getting made and [__] like
that I support the idea of a king verse
even any way shape or form look even
better make a whole movie King verse
movies set in Castle Rock just make a TV
show called Castle Rock and do all that
[__] [__] in just the weirdest
[__] [__] in the world happens in his
I always have when I was a kid it's you
know [__] reading The Shining dude is
like you know first I read like um
catcher aai that was my Bible then I
read The Shining that became my Bible
then Christine I [__] loved Christine
and stuff so you know I even liked I
wouldn't paid cash money see Maximum
Overdrive wow remember it had the
[__] Green Goblin head on the truck
clown truck oh we were like ohly [__]
[__] but I'm happy to see and also they
got this new series on Hulu right now
with 2263 and that's a Stephen King book
JJ ABS did show have you seen it yet I
haven't seen it yet I think it just
dropped today yesterday really good
reviews um but and I love the fact that
that Stephen King does what he calls the
dollar option where he calls them dollar
babies where if you single this man if
you want to option A Stephen King story
you pay him a dollar really yes almost
anybody granted he will get full boat if
you get this thing set up down the line
he gets his money then he gets his money
then but like if you're a student
filmmaker and you want to make a thing
write him a letter if you're daraban and
you want to make a thing dollar that's
what it'll cost you wow and he loves the
idea that movies are getting made he
loves the idea that anybody like the the
cost of a movie should not prohibit an
artist from taking a run at it like if
you come with a good thing if you write
a great script offer this thing that you
paid me a dollar for then we're in
business it's such a smart play because
it's it's like hey man if there's a
movie I'm going to sell 100,000 more
books of a book that I've sold millions
of copies of already and you know that's
that's how they roll so it's smart good
for him man that's happening all right
let's look at the rest and let kids get
out of here man Amen brother Gotham
gotam goam is happening you ain't
watching it but somebody is cuz [__]
they keep the show on the air and stuff
and God damn it it just it's it seems
like this is the year they hit their STP
in terms of like we're throwing [__]
everything at you bangs and [__] they're
just going nuts they're introduced uh
the uh character of azreel yes from the
order of St dumah Joe cada designed the
character of azreel is that the suit
that is James FR playing azreel so he's
got to put the mask on got to put the
mask on oh my god there he
is wow wow dude it's nuts it's crazy I
wonder if Joe cada gets happy about Joe
cada Marvel big wig and has been for
[__] you know what two decades now
and stuff he created that character he
was a visual he drew it and stuff so I
wonder if he gets h i mean he could turn
on [__] well number one he's
producing Daredevils and [__] so he can
like see his work come to life there but
that's like early deep Cuts one of his
like he used to draw Batman and stuff
like that you can't get jok out to draw
Batman anymore man because he's Marvel
guy but that was his character I wonder
if he gets like excited when he sees
that picture does he go like holy [__]
it's azreel or is he just like please
dude I've seen the Black Panther like my
toy box is way more [__] deep than
that and [__] or do you think he's just
like man that's [__] cool pretty
sweet and also my agent where's my
profit participation yeah that's the
call he's like [__] sweet I want my
taste yeah come on I invented that [__]
where's my money that's crazy I can't
believe we're in a world where they're
going to do [__] asra me I know we
say it all the time in the show but on
the heels of Gotham doing corn of vals
with you know [__] Theo Gallivan and
just and he is the Theo galivan is the
character yes so he di in the winter
finale spoilers played by the actor
James FR who's that dude and he's coming
back to be asre
yep deep Cuts it's deep Cuts dude that's
deeper Cuts quter Val is at least
current Cuts you know deep Cuts but
current [__] azreal is that is like
92 93 DC that was like [__] Kevin
Smith hey day DC early 90s and [__] this
is like Clerk's country [__] like that
that's how deep they're pulling from
gotam but I don't know
like I I what is it why how come we're
not like I just watched why will I watch
every episode of flash like and it's my
[__] my piece dude like I watched did
you watch you watched [__] I watched
The Welcome To Earth 2 episode yes when
he gets the call when the the he calls
his mom on the phone she leaves him a
message oh we'll talk about that in the
next episode cuz it was [__]
beautiful but like so they do superhero
show or comic book show that I'll tune
in for every [__] week and when
Daredevil's on I watch it from top to
bottom just like Jessica Jones why and
even though if they're announcing on
Gotham [__] azreel Dr Mr Freeze
[__] Dr Hugo Strange they're pulling
out all the stops and still I'm like
well maybe I'll wait till the end of the
season what is it why won't I I think
it's because Show's called Fat Man on
Batman what's my problem it's a little
it's a lot too late is what it feels
like to me is that they gave us that
first season which you know we had
issues with as many people did and it
feels like this year for the second
season they are just kind of
overcompensating for the fact that
there's no Batman by giving us
everything around Batman you want a show
called Gotham to kind of be about Batman
or even to be about James Gordon and it
doesn't even seem to be about James
Gordon they've left him kind of behind
as well yeah so it's now just like it's
it's guest star of the week it's costume
of the week it's power of the week and
you're like well but which is what I
asked for in season 1 I was like just
make it like [__]
Batman 66 but in the Modern Age where
every week There's a [__] villain
it's a guest star I'm doing it and I
should be tuning in but what stopping
but flash also does that like every you
get the [__] turtle and you get like
this guy and you get Killer Croc and you
get all that stuff but at its core like
you know what that show is you know why
I'm tuning in every week and it's
because I want to see what Barry does I
want to see what happens to Barry this
week I want to see how he navigates his
Irish relationship his Joe relationship
his Zoom relationship I want to see the
[__] soap joy that is watching this
kind of show and Gotham is not giv that
to us yeah they better well I hope they
keep going I mean I would like for them
to at some point do the that old Great
Battle Star trick where it's you
remember in the tail end of season two
where like balar has now like they've
landed on new cpra and Baltar is he's
now the president and he's in colonial
one super [__] happy and then he puts
his head down and he picks it back up
and it's one year later they literally
just jump on a cut to one year later the
silons have invaded it's now occupied
Capra and it's the worst thing ever
right like I need the jump cut 10 years
from now where that [__] kid is now
Bruce Wayne that would be your season
three you know like if I'm those cats
I'm like look I know you guys are doing
the movies and stuff but like we got to
hail marry this [__] yeah like we got to
do Batman year One or we're done smart
good call I mean that's just me if I
read well people AR make gol like [__]
both of you you suck we got to do the
show every week like I know I [__]
I'm I'm all for dude and I will watch
Gotham at the end of the season all the
episodes collected and stuff but uh yeah
it's just I don't know we talk about it
and we read about it and like we showed
pictures and I'm like oh my God but like
I'm not setting my phone or anything
like that yeah there's nothing emotional
to draw us through and to keep us tied
Tethered to this show and that's the
thing dude it's emotion like you think
about it as much as you love watching
[__] punch other [__]
in the face for the good or for the bad
whatever the [__] it's the emotional
background the storyline that like
always gets you and like Daredevil has
that you know and and Gotham should have
more of it but there's something like it
they need to pick like I know it's like
it's a Jim Gordon show but it feels like
just make it about the boy and Alfred
you know what I'm saying and like
villains yes but like they don't have to
I don't know I don't know I I you know
like the DI is cast at this point and
you can only you can only and not in a
bad way where it's like yeah it is and
boy it sucks like they're doing a good
job but it's like yeah feels like
they're throwing a party feels like
they're making a pirates the Caribbean
without John joh Depp right and it's
like it could be the best Pirates of the
Caribbean but you're like something's
missing yeah I kind of want that guy
yeah you know and boy's good don't get
me wrong the boy's real good but it's
just
like we want to see him grown up like
maybe that would be the case maybe they
should like every jump every season
should jump a few years yeah you know
and like don't even if you can't put him
in the in the suit don't put him in the
suit but give me Bruce Wayne at 19 give
me angry [__] Bruce Wayne yeah give
me the trial run before for Batman give
us what they gave us in that trailer the
blur Studios that Tim Miller did for
that video game that Batman Arkham night
video game where you know they went
through Bruce's life and you just watch
the pain [__] the reverberation of
his parents getting killed throughout
his life and you watch him
age been nice if they did that whatever
they're still they're doing fine I'm
sure they don't need our [__] help
but that's what that'd be the that's a
smart call that's that's what gets me
coming back cuz then you can like do
within your season flashback episodes to
like [__] that happened and you could
bring little boy back like hey young
Bruce again but and then you stop
dealing with like baby versions of the
villains then you get to deal with oh oh
there's poison ivy there's Catwoman and
there's like I get that you're attached
to these actors but at some point you
got to give me if I had a [__]
Network this is who I'd hire right there
I'd hired him to run that Network and
then I'd quit the network and I'd be
like clearly you're a better man than I
am gunga den and I'd give him my network
and I'd leave I think that's how that
story end probably i'
I saw it once when Mr meoo did it it was
very
moving um lastly Supergirl over at the
beran universe man [__] berlan verse
killing it my God that last The Flash
going to [__] we'll talk about
another episode flash going Earth too oh
copious tears um Supergirl as we saw
last week they did the black Mercy
episode now Supergirl going for broke
dude foress of solitude they're going to
show you the Fortress of Solitude we had
christberg on look at that [__] dude
look at it so many crystals see it
children so is this meant to be C's home
uh yeah I think so and it's very uh you
know it's very dony very Doner I was
going to say yeah um you're not [__]
around no [__] dude when christberg was
on a podcast he talked about like we're
going to go for it like it's Superman as
far as we're concerned superg girl we're
telling that story but like we could
take all the elements and we're going to
do these things and like if we get one
season we're going to make it the best
season and they are dude like they're
[__] throwing in everything they're
going to get more seasons I believe
because they're [__] doing it right
now that we've got the big crossover to
look forward to and in that [__]
flash uh welcome to to Earth 2 episode
there's that picture look at them
together D so [__] adorable he saw
her when he was [__] when he jumped
into the time oh he saw her in the time
stream it was awesome so awesome could
those guys look like they're having any
more fun that I'm going to find out dude
I'm going up there like a spy in the
house of love a couple weeks to go
shooting that a direct an episode of
flash direct I'm going to stand there
and watch talented people work and be
like cut I guess um we'll see how happy
they are they all look [__] so happy
I know that's why I'm going I'm like
give me some of your happy rub some of
that [__] happy take your emblems and
rub all over stuff remember the
beginning of the Season people like
there's going to be a crossover and
people like there is no crossover can't
ever happen and then all a sudden
they're like oh it's happening and we
shot it and here's a picture and
everything great time to be alive ah so
good there it is dude all the news
that's [__] to print we gave it to you
right here I'm Fat Man on Batman the
only show that Combs the internet for
news and just reads it to you like we're
[__] Russian newscasters man in the
80s um good time to be alive all good
news there today kids no bad news and
[__] don't nobody bring me no bad news
no bad news no bad news remember that I
remember that ain't nobody bring me no
bad news remember her throne at the end
when they killed the wicked witch is a
toilet closes like a toilet seat oh The
Whiz I love that when I was Kid The Whiz
toilet seat it's all it's all [__]
dick potty
jokes thank you Barry gy you know who
else worked on it production designer I
believe and it ties into this show
Fatman on Batman Joel schacher oh yes
everything's connected folks
everything's connected Can you feel a
brand new day that's because it's
[__] we live in a post Deadpool World
[__] it's all good now things are still
changing uh there it is Batman on Batman
give it up for [__] Mark Bernard and
the Kevin Smith told [__] how
to run their Network and their show and
he's he's right those are good ideas
dude right is I'm telling you as soon as
I [__] get a network I'm goingon to
be like run it run it write all my shows
and then you're going to write 25 shows
and you're going to hate this [__] cuz
you're like oh [__] dude I just wanted
one I'm like do it all can I go take a
[__] no write another show I just want I
can't remember my name if Mark remembers
his name is Rumple
stillin then I can't use him to fuel my
network Z skim he's from the [__]
eighth Dimension uh there it is man for
Batman I'm Batman I've been Kevin Smith
Mark Berard come back uh next episode
man same fat Time same fat Channel
youtube.com/ Kevin
Smith hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks
for watching do me a favor click that
thing below that says subscribe every
time you click that you save a baby
kitten from murder